[Applause]
[Music]
ukraine
is the paris hilton of countries every
time they are mentioned in the media
it's usually because something bad has
happened when we think of ukraine we
think of chernobyl the war with russia
or the corruption scandal that led to
trump's first
impeachment
[Music]
and the truth is that ukrainian history
is a real tearjerker seriously if one
day you get
fired from your job and your partner
leaves you or any other misfortune
happens to you
read something about the history of
ukraine or watch this video and i
promise
it will make you feel better we are
talking after all about the poorest
country
in europe in terms of gdp per capita
ukrainians are as poor as citizens of el
salvador or turkmenistan however all
this could change and we're about to see
the moment of truth in the coming months
the president of ukraine
faces the great dilemma on which the
future of his country depends
by the end of this video you'll have a
better idea of what i'm talking about
but
why is ukraine so poor
[Music]
and some will say it's obvious grant
ukraine belonged to the soviet union
they had a communist past and now
they're poor however there are many
other countries that were also
part of the soviet orbit and are now
prosperous democracies with a good
quality of life poland the czech
republic
and estonia are now prosperous countries
with living standards comparable to
any european country and curiously
poland and the czech republic
are now full of ukrainians ukrainians
who come for a few months to work for
example in construction and then return
to their country
[Music]
in fact almost 12 percent of ukraine's
entire gdp
comes from remittances from abroad it's
estimated that more than 10
million ukrainians work abroad even if
only for a few months a year and i say
it is estimated because most of the
ukrainian economy is informal
remember we are talking about a country
that is currently an open war
with russia and no that is not the only
reason why they are so poor so the
questions we are asking today are
just why is ukraine so poor what is
going on in this country where 30 years
after leaving communism they're worse
off than they were as part of the soviet
union today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but first let's look at a
little bit of history
capitalism that never came to be have
you ever heard
about the antonov aircraft it is the
largest aircraft
in the world by the way if you want to
know all the technical details of this
flying colossus you can check out this
video on our sister channel
megaprojects well this technical prodigy
is made entirely in ukraine yes ukraine
is one of the nine countries in the
world where you can manufacture
airplanes without ever leaving the
country they have the entire aerospace
production chain within their own
borders few countries can boast
so much technology
and despite all this though ukraine is
still as poor as turkmenistan or el
salvador and if you don't find that
intriguing here's another fact
ukraine has natural resources of all
kinds iron uranium and
all kinds of metals they also have some
of the most fertile land for agriculture
in the world i'm talking about the
so-called chernozem
or black earth which is a type of soil
that is apparently fantastic for growing
crops in fact for
decades ukraine was the bread basket of
the soviet union despite all this
ukraine has suffered a nazi
and then a soviet invasion during
stalin's time the population was
subjected to one of the most terrible
famines in history so-called holodomor
and after the fall of communism ukraine
was one of the poorest republics in the
entire
soviet orbit
a country that was also divided into two
large groups russian-speaking people who
were in the eastern regions and the
ukrainian-speaking people who were in
the west
as you can imagine these divisions go
beyond language the ukrainian-speaking
population wants ukraine to become a
market economy
trading with europe the russian-speaking
population wants to maintain a
centralized economy
and maintain trade ties with russia and
all of this explains why ukraine had
never had a real transition to
capitalism proof of this is that to this
day they still have over 3
600 state-owned enterprises and all this
has to do with how they privatized their
economy
[Music]
to make this easy think of it this way
soviet communism was based on a
state-run economy that is
all enterprises were state-owned from
the big energy companies to the last
chocolate factory therefore the most
important step in a transition from
communism to capitalism is to privatize
almost
all these enterprises and this is why
ukraine poland estonia the czech
republic and almost all the countries of
the former soviet union underwent
privatization processes in the 1990s
however as we always say here on
visualpolitik the devil is in the
details
for a better understanding let's compare
the privatization cases of the czech
republic with those in ukraine if you've
been subscribed to this channel for a
long time you already know this story
because we have told you it more than
once
if you're not subscribed to
visualpolitik what are you doing with
your life subscribe now and hit the
little bell button so you don't miss any
of our cool updates but for now
let's get back to our story
[Music]
after the fall of soviet communism the
czech government calculated the value of
all its enterprises and divided it
into vouchers these vouchers were then
sold to citizens at a moderate price
in fact 80 of citizens bought some of
these vouchers which could later be
exchanged for company
shares in other words when the
government auctioned the company in
question it was relatively easy to buy
shares in the company today
almost every czech citizen owns shares
in shed companies
all this explains why the czech republic
is one of the most egalitarian countries
in the world
few people know it but the czech
republic is one of the countries with
the smallest gap between rich and poor
in the world they even surpass the
nordic countries
[Music]
the case of ukraine though is completely
different yes it is true the state also
sold
vouchers to office enterprises to
citizens but with a difference
let's imagine that we are ukrainian
citizen in the 1990s working in that
chocolate factory we talked about
earlier the state tells us that it's
going to privatize the company and that
for the equivalent of 1
500 we can buy a stake when the company
is auctioned we can exchange our small
piece of paper for a package of shares
so far
so good right well no the problem is is
that this piece of paper is not worth
anything until the company is auctioned
and we can exchange it for real shares
and that moment never comes think about
it the elites ruling the new ukraine
were the same that had been in power
during the soviet union they only
changed the name of the party from the
communist party to the social democratic
party otherwise the same faces the same
ideas
and same interests so what's the
conclusion well you had a voucher that
was good for
nothing and that is when the oligarch of
the moment arrives a gentleman by the
name of petro poroshenko
remember that name because it will be
important later on well this
petro poroshenko and many others like
him is a gentleman well connected with
the government who has raised some money
with friends and relatives and this
nice gentleman comes to us and he says
look that little piece of paper you have
is worthless and you need money right
well i'll give you a hundred dollars for
it and at least you can pay rent this
month so
what do you do well obviously you sell
it to and just after mr porridge uncle
bought the paper from me and all my
co-workers
turns out surprise the steak comes and
auctions the chocolate factory in other
words for very little money poroshenko
has taken over the ownership of an
entire
chocolate factory take that willy wonka
and so this is how the roshin group was
born in 1996 which today is the leading
manufacturer of sweets in ukraine
[Music]
in fact mr poroshenko is known as the
king
of chocolate so poroshenko is an example
of
an oligarch
[Music]
to give you an idea it's estimated that
85 of ukraine's wealth is in the hands
of oligarchs we could say the oligarchs
are kind of like the american dream but
a horrible twisted version of it they
are big businessmen who become rich
thanks to political favors so actually
they're exactly like the american dream
for example do you remember the chair
knows them that is so fertile for
cultivation well
almost all farmland in ukraine is in the
hands of just 25 landowners and you will
say
what's the problem with that that's the
market my friend well it's certainly not
until recently the sale and purchase of
agricultural land in ukraine
was prohibited in other words the
oligarchs took over the land during the
privatizations and the law protects them
to keep it
no matter what happens ukrainian
agriculture is totally unproductive
despite having hyper fertile land 70 of
the land produces half as much per
hectare as the united states on top of
all this we have to add corruption
scandals and state-owned companies to
give you an idea the largest company in
the country is naftogas i'm so sorry
ukrainians naftalgaz is the ukrainian
state gas company which belongs as you
guess
to the state according to a think tank
in kiev corruption in this company
accounts for more than 3
billion a year and obviously all this
corruption translates into losses
in the millions
[Music]
in 2014 alone naftoga's losses accounted
for more than 60 percent
of ukrainian gdp in other words ukraine
is poor in large part because of the
corruption of the ukrainian elites
themselves
but i know what many of you are thinking
let's see technically ukraine is at war
with russia
right they're whole regions overrun by
russia does this really not have an
economic impact and yes
it does we're gonna check that out right
now
the moment of truth unless you live in a
cave sorry everyone who lives in wales
you will know that russia and ukraine
are bitter enemies this was started
after the euro maidan protests
thousands of young people took to the
streets of kiev to protest against the
government they were violently repressed
by the police but eventually they
succeeded in
overthrowing the pro-russian government
of victory
what you all probably don't know is why
all this started think about it until
2014 most ukrainians did not want to
join nato at that time russia was the
country's main trading partner so what
happened for the situation to have taken
such
a drastic turn well it all started
because of this piece of news
ukraine suspends talks on eu trade pact
as putin wins tug of war
the guardian to summarize until 2013
russia was ukraine's main trading
partner russia sold its gas
and ukraine sold its metals and grain
however ukraine did not want to be so
dependent
on the kremlin and that's what led them
to start negotiating for a free trade
agreement with a european union
at the end of 2013 the president of
ukraine was about to sign such a treaty
but putin
pressured him to back out remember i was
telling you that ukraine is divided into
two halves all the ukrainian speaking
half considered that vetoing of this
treaty was a betrayal and
that is what caused the euromaidan
protests to break out these protests
serve to overthrow yanukovych and then
the russian-speaking half felt betrayed
and what are the regions with the most
russian speakers in the whole country
crimea
donetsk and luhansk
these three regions wanted to deceive
from the rest of ukraine
russia supported the separatists and
that's how the ukrainian war broke out
[Music]
we will talk about all of this in depth
in another video but today we are going
to focus on the economy because
the first economic consequence of this
war was the end of trade with russia
take a look at this graph
[Applause]
as you can see when ukraine stops
trading with russia it starts trading
with the european union as of today
brussels is kiev's main trading partner
and many of you would think that this
was a whole new beginning for ukraine a
change
of course the end of the pro-russian
oligarchy right well not really can you
guess who was the next ukrainian
president after the deposed yanukovych
listen up
[Music]
chocolate king poroshenko wins ukraine
presidency but violence continues
the conversation that's right the
ukrainian willy wonka
ukraine replaced the russian-speaking
oligarchy with the ukrainian
speaking oligarchy everything changed in
order for everything to stay the same
since then ukraine has promised a myriad
of anti-corruption schemes several civil
society platforms have emerged to bring
the most blatant cases to court but at
the same time the elites and kiev have
tried to put on the brakes on as many of
these proposals as possible and so it
continued
until 2019 what happened then we're
gonna take a look at that
no
[Music]
general cleaning do you remember the
first impeachment against trump i know
there were so many
if you remember it all started because
trump allegedly promised some military
aid to ukraine in exchange for opening
an investigation against biden
it was 2019 and that's how the world met
the new ukrainian president
vladimir zelenski
of teaching
[Music]
okay let me put you in the picture
imagine that martin sheen after playing
the role of the president of the united
states in the west wing is running for
president of the united states
but for real well that is exactly the
case with zelensky we are talking about
a tv actor and comedian who became
famous for playing the role of the
president of ukraine at the high point
of his acting career he ran for election
few would have bet on his political
career but against all the odds in may
2019 he won the election
over petro poroshenko so long willy
wonka his message was i am neither
pro-russian nor anti-russian my enemy is
corruption and oligarchs and that
explains why under his government
measures like this have been passed
[Music]
ukrainian parliament adopts law on
opening farmland markets starting july
baker mckenzie do you remember those
laws that shielded the ukrainian
oligarchs well
little by little the ukrainian
government is changing them in february
2021 they froze the accounts of another
pro-russian oligarch billionaire victor
medvedev
all these measures are very important
for ukraine they serve not only
to clean up the country but they are
also essential for allowing it to
receive
international aid for example ukraine
has asked for a 5 billion
loan from the international monetary
fund but this loan will only come if
ukraine is serious about its fight
against corruption at this point i know
what many of you are thinking zelensky
must be a hero to the ukrainians right
the man who is wielding justice against
all the oligarchs
right well he's not zalenski began his
presidency with
huge popularity ratings but in the last
year he has plummeted what's more his
party took a real beating in the last
municipal elections many would think
that this is all due to the karuna virus
these are bad times to govern
any country but remember we are talking
about ukraine the country of the
ukrainian dream which is like the
american dream
but worse achieving success in ukraine
without counting on the oligarchs is
practically
impossible and that also includes
zelensky
us imposes sanctions on ukrainian
oligarch igor kolomisky
over alleged corruption financial times
and this
is where the real moment of truth comes
for ukraine who is
igor kolomorsky you may ask well none
other than the owner of this tv station
where zelensky became famous
and not only that he is also one of the
main supporters of the current president
of ukraine
so much so that he's even been his chief
of staff during the first years of his
presidency in other words
even the scourge of corruption in
ukraine has depended on an oligarch to
get himself known and what is good old
kolomoisky accused of well you see
in addition to owning a television
station kolomoisky was the owner of a
private bank
private bank the bank is responsible for
a fraud that has cost the state coffers
more than 5.5 billion dollars so we're
talking about corruption
on a grand scale and this as i said is
the real moment of truth for zelensky
the usual thing in these cases would be
for the government to bend
over backwards to save him from jail it
would not be the first time that a
ukrainian oligarch gets off scot-free
from her trial
thanks to his political connections
in other words ukraine is in a real
dilemma the outcome of this dilemma is
key to the future of the country and so
now the question is over to you will it
be different this time will zelinski
allow his friend to be put on trial is
ukraine really ready to do away with
oligarchic elites and end corruption is
it possible that ukraine will be rich
one day and
just how badly did i butcher all those
names you can leave your answers in the
comments below and as always don't
forget that we release new videos
every week so subscribe to visualpolitik
and hit the little bell down there so
you don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video
please give it a thumbs up and we'll see
you next time take it easy
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there